[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Sandwich
crackers are one
of life's little conveniences--
crispy wafers with peanut butter
or cheese spread between them
all wrapped up in
a neat package.
In North America,
factories have been mass
producing these snacks since the
early part of the 20th century
to satisfy the need to nibble.
Sandwich crackers come in
handy for a quick refuel.
Just unwrap and snack while
continuing on your routine.
They start with the smaller
ingredients for the dough,
which include baking soda,
a powdered cheese additive,
and a kind of phosphate,
which, like the baking soda,
is a leavening agent.
Next are enzyme
tablets and the yeast,
two ingredients that
will later cause
the dough to ferment to give
the crackers textural strength.
They add water and
thicken the liquefied
blend with a little flour.
This makes it easier to
pump into the next mixer.
This one is a big
trough full of flour.
They add ice to chill
it and then pipe
in the small ingredient blend.
Cooling the mix with ice
preserves the yeast and enzymes
to hold off on fermentation.
If fermentation
happens too soon,
the dough could turn to mush.
They lower a lid equipped
with three spiraling blades
and set the blades in
motion, pumping in more water
to augment the moisture
from the melting ice
and small ingredient blend.
It's now ready for fermentation,
so it's into a warm room
to activate the yeast
and the enzymes.
The dough swells
and a worker breaks
the crust to release gas.
An automated system
tips the trough of dough
into a chute that
takes it one floor
down to the rolling station.
The chemical changes
caused by fermentation
have made this
dough less sticky,
so it can now be rolled
into sheets without adhering
to the equipment.
The dough now travels
between rollers
that flatten it and squeeze
it to a specific thickness.
The sheets of dough
exit and accumulate.
When several layers have piled
up, the dough is on the move
again.
Several layers at a
time now, it moves
between a series of rollers,
which compress the dough
to its final thickness.
A quick dust with
flour and the dough
now goes under a rolling
cutter that scores
it to cracker-size proportions.
The cutter is also spiked with
pins that puncture the dough.
The holes give the
crackers a dimpled look,
and they have a
practical purpose--
allowing steam to escape during
cooking for a crispier snack.
A sprinkle of salt
and the cracker dough
now heads into the oven.
This oven is more
than 65 yards long
with several heating zones.
The hottest is around
700 degrees Fahrenheit.
A roller breaks them cleanly
along the scorelines.
A quick spray with
vegetable oil adds flavor.
The crackers then transfer
from one conveyor to another
and land in neat stacks.
They head into an
inspection station
where workers pick out
any damaged crackers
and adjust the alignment
of the shingled rows
so it's a smooth transition as
the crackers move into lanes.
Down the line, workers pull
off samples to weigh them.
Then equipment flips the
crackers upright, positioning
them to enter the filling line.
The peanut butter
filling is ready
and kept warm so it's smooth
and creamy enough to pump.
The top crackers
now head downward
in a precise
configuration, while below,
the bottom crackers whiz by
the peanut butter depositor.
It pumps a dollop
of peanut butter
onto each bottom cracker.
The peanut butter-covered
bottom crackers
now move forward to meet
up with the top crackers.
And again with perfect
timing, the top
crackers land on the bottom
ones in exact alignment.
Equipment separates
them into sets of three
as they head into packaging.
Plastic wrap envelops
them, and a heat sealer
cuts and closes the packets.
Suctioning arms
collect the packets
and transfer them
to cardboard boxes.
From mixing to packaging,
it has taken about 24 hours
to produce a packet
of sandwich crackers.
Once it reaches
a hungry snacker,
it will be gone
in no time at all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]